Here we're talking about
project based learning.
And if you're in this class,
you're already familiar with
project-based learning,
because this entire class
is project-based learning.
We built it on that foundation.
Project-based learning is a pedagogical
technique where students learn through
big long-term projects.
Sometimes somewhat open-ended,
as opposed to through small written
assignments or quizzes or tests.
There are a lot of real benefits
to project-based learning and
one of my favorites is
the idea of authenticity.
Typically, when we go into the actual
fields that we're teaching about,
what were our work is,
is actually pretty project-based.
We do big long-term projects,
rather than small tasks each day.
And so by teaching students
using project-based learning,
we're not only teaching them
the content we want them to know.
But we're also teaching them what
it's like to actually be a part of
that field.
And similarly, personalization is
a really big benefit of this as well.
Typically, when students do a project,
they actually feel some personal
connection to what they've produced.
And some of the projects we've done are
other OMS classes we've seen students
really develop the projects and
pursue them after the semester is over.
Some of them have gone so
far as to name their projects or
give them personalities.
There's really a personal
connection between the student and
the project that they develop.
The longer term and more open-ended
nature of the project also
means that we can do some things
to facilitate real learning.
And the more important
learning strategies that we
want students to develop.
Things like planning what they're going
to do, monitoring how it's going and
adjusting it accordingly if
it's not going very well.
Oftentimes in traditional education,
by the time a student recognizes that
what they're doing isn't working.
It might be too late to fix it,
if it's a test or a quiz or something.
But with projects, the longer term
nature of them gives students time to
recognize what I've been working
on isn't really working.
How can I evaluate it?
How can I recover?
So there are a lot of benefits
of project-based learning.
The difficulty is that they
aren't always easy to implement
in a regular classroom.
Projects are bigger and
they're open-ended and
they're very personal to students.
And that makes it very difficult
to give students feedback on them,
it makes it difficult to grade projects.
How do you grade two
students that did very,
very different projects if it's
a very open-ended project?
Presents a lot of difficulty, but that's
where technology can really play a role.
Technology gives us
an environment in which we can
allow students to produce
some open-ended projects.
And have built in functionalities
to develop their ideas and
construct whatever
they want to construct.
And through some
artificial intelligence,
we can actually start to build in
some of that feedback directly into
the environment.
We can give them feedback right in the
context of what they're doing without
requiring a teacher to be consistently
monitoring what they're doing.
So technology can really bring
project-based learning to life.
And so we'll talk about the different
ways in which project-based learning can
be done and how technology can help.